[Music]
amasses funeral for the mastermind of
iran's nuclear programme
assassinated on friday and now buried
with full military honours in the
capital tiran
moshin fakhrazadeh had been at the heart
of the country's nuclear ambitions for
two decades
a scientist and a brigadier general in
the revolutionary guard
the country's defense minister spoke
over his shoulder alongside the dead
scientist iran's top
general assassinated in january by the
americans
no crime no assassination and no foolish
action will be left without a response
by the iranian nation
we will certainly hunt down criminals
until the end
they must know that they will be
punished for their actions
as his body was lowered into the ground
consensus here and globally
is that this was the work of there are
two
israel
varying accounts of what happened on
friday afternoon
initially iranian authorities said
multiple gunmen were involved in the
shooting
which happened after an explosion near
the scientist's car
but now other iranian officials talk of
an extraordinary level of sophistication
an unmanned automatic weapon controlled
via satellite and mounted within a car
which then self-destructed unfortunately
the operation was a very complicated one
and was carried out using electronic
devices no individual was present at the
site
we found clues and the person who
designed the operation is known to us
sapond is led by the same person who led
project ahmad
dr zadeh two years ago the israeli prime
minister
introduced the world to iran's top
scientist
of course the israelis have admitted
nothing nor will they definitively at
least but assuming this was israel the
aims are clear firstly to disrupt a
nuclear program which they believe
is progressing all the time the purpose
of which they say
is to destroy israel and the second aim
perhaps more important to make it harder
for joe biden
the incoming american president to
re-sign the nuclear deal
that obama did with iran the one donald
trump
pulled out of ever since that historic
deal was signed the israelis and gulf
arab nations have said it is flawed
because it's time limited they say iran
will hoodwink the world and make a
weapon anyway
by killing the top scientist the message
is
talking and deals don't work with iran
the risk is
a chain reaction retaliation back and
forth and an iran more intent than ever
in obtaining a nuclear weapon mark stone
sky news
in israel